[Music]
[Music]
huffman
oh it's you two
thank you for coming
so
the dark knight hero
do you have anything else you're able to
share with me
is that so that is a pity indeed the
situation is
here take a look at this
geez what horrible handwriting
hmm
let me take a closer look
huh
some parts of this seem to be complete
gibberish
indeed
although this is written in the common
tongue it appears that a cipher has been
used in many places
nevertheless one can grasp the general
message from the non-ciphered portions
alone
this is a war declaration from the abyss
order to the dark knight hero
does that mean
the bad guys want the dark knight hero
to go away forever and ever
something like that
thus we are hoping to contact him as
soon as possible so that we can attempt
to coordinate a response
after all this matter no longer concerns
merely the dark knight hero himself if
you find out anything at all
come and find me
[Music]
declaration sent by the abyss order
this is not good news at all from master
d luke quick we should go tell him right
away
yep
just now we were at the knights of
evonius and
and
i take it you're about to inform me of
the war declaration from the abyss order
i'm aware of it
though i appreciate you for taking the
trouble to come all this way
what
the don winery's intelligence network
extends beyond commercial matters
great
so
what's the plan master d luke
i'm open to suggestions
no
that would be playing right into the
hands of the abyss order
they know full well that we don't
exactly see eye to eye
they're using this as a means to force
me into making an appearance
if my identity were exposed all my
future activities would be subject to
some degree of interference from the
knights
after all
no powerful organization wishes to be
outdone by someone from the outside
whoa the abyss orders really tell you a
tough hand this time
what a sneaky little bunch those guys
are
there is a way
but for it to work i need some more
information
specifically i need to decipher the
obscured portions of the abyss orders
war declaration
obscured portions you mean the bits
pymon can't read
it must be a cipher only understood by
members of the abyss order
used to spread messages within the
organization
it's not simply a war declaration
but also a notification to their own
when you take a stand that makes you a
hero to one party you also become a
villain to the other
and since i've been the abyss orders
enemy for so long
they've made me the target around which
they can rally their troops and unite
their strengths
wow
seems like it takes a lot of brains to
be a superhero huh
i understand my enemy well is all
as the saying goes heroes and villains
are two sides of the same coin
so what are we gonna do about the intel
that's written in gibberish then
how do we
un-gibberish
by it
simple
when you don't understand something
you ask
i've already tracked down one of their
strongholds
if you're interested
feel free to come along
this is the place abandoned ruins like
these are precisely the kind of come on
there's no time to lose
uh
shhh
hey
yeah
huh
let's light it up
retribution
[Music]
[Music]
furnitures
let's light it up
i'm going in
time for
retribution
[Music]
[Music]
oh so sorry
let's spark things
now start talking
your plan what is it
i see you received our letter
but if you think i'm going to let you in
on our secrets i'm afraid you're quite
mistaken
you appear to have misunderstood the
situation you're in
did you just use a viral vision to shoot
fire from your hands
burns
let's see how long it takes for you to
crack please
please stop
hero
they will march on the monster city
gates at 10 p.m tomorrow night
that's everything i know
please
don't make me suffer those flames again
that's it
well i doubt you'd be foolish enough to
keep anything else hidden
oh
uh
now that i have the information i need i
must prepare
i would be grateful if you could keep me
updated on how the knights of fivonius
respond to this matter
yes master t luke sir anything you say
master d luke sir
why are you acting so strange all of a
sudden
and
in light of what just went down here a
moment ago
master d luke has officially reached
number one on pymon's people not to take
off under any circumstances listen
if we do not make contact with the dark
knight hero soon
ah it's you two i must admit
this issue of the dark knight hero is
proving to be something of a headache
we've just held a meeting to decide on
an appropriate course of action
can you guess what it is
no that would send a signal that the
knights are in favor of the dark
knight's hero's continued presence in
our city which we are not encouraging
this kind of individual heroism
undermines the night's authority
oh
well what's the plan then
find out the dark knight hero's true
identity and offer him our protection
protection
he seems to be doing just fine without
your protection so far you know
well
since you've aided the knights in the
past i might as well just tell you
the offer of protection is just a ruse
in order for the knights of fivonius to
take over full and exclusive
responsibility for this matter
you aren't gonna let the dark knight
hero be all heroic and stuff why not
firstly to show the might of the knights
of fevonius to prove to the people that
without the dark knight hero they can
still rely on the knights to maintain
peace and harmony
secondly the abyss order have no mercy
in their hearts
if anything happened to the dark knight
hero it would only serve to further
their nefarious ambitions
gosh
pyma never knew the life of the night
involved so much untold anguish before
but none of this will work if we don't
establish the dark knight hero's true
identity in time
there's no need to despair huffman
just follow my plan and everything will
be fine
ah captain kaya
lately master d luke has been working
the bar at the angels share every night
all i need you to do is keep him in your
sight
think you can manage that for me
uh yes captain kaia
but
does that mean that
master d luke is the dark knight hero
who knows it's just a hunch
i've been known to be wrong on occasion
wow
pymon feels we saw a whole new side of
the knights of evonius today
but pymon doesn't understand